I wouldn't say I'm particularly excited
about it 30 30 hit me pretty hard 40
will hit me hard my wife always says
growing old as a growing older is a
privilege
Luke Bryan will be celebrating the big
four all away from home this year thanks
to his kill delights North American tour
Caroline has offered me to pick what I
want to do for my birthday so we're
gonna probably get get some friends
together and try to go somewhere fishing
or something like that the superstars
first-ever EP farm tour here's to the
farmer will hit stores this September
and a new full-length album is also in
the works I've gotten better about not
writing all the time I mean I used to
you know have so much pressure on me in
this business I felt that that writing
constantly was the weather ever come
that so now I've kind of slowed down I
would say I already had three or four
songs that I'm really really excited
about for the next LP but we don't have
that date picture and with Luke's BFF
Blake Shelton spending so much time with
his new love Gwen Stefani don't expect a
blue-green Yin or collaboration anytime
soon they seem to be really enjoying
each other got to hang out with Blake at
CMT Awards a couple a couple weeks ago
and he needs a same old Blake and as far
as collaborations with you know that
would actually have to put me around him
more than I would uh particularly care
for
you